tomorrow we Mark a grim anniversary in
this country five years since the
deadliest mass shooting in modern U.S
history 58 people killed hundreds of
others wounded at a country music
festival on the Las Vegas Strip in 2017.
a gunman opened fire from The Mandalay
Bay Hotel shooting downward and into the
crowd a new four-part documentary from
our streaming service Paramount plus
it's called 11 minutes features in-depth
interviews with people who were there
that night among them are concert goers
First Responders and musician Jason
Aldean who was performing he was on
stage when the gunfire started here is a
preview of the documentary and as you
might expect we do need to warn you some
of this may be disturbing to watch take
a look
Vegas was always one of the shows for me
that I always look forward to
the best thing ever that was my first
country concert I was excited I was like
all right let's do this
[Applause]
that's when the world changed for us
[Applause]
automatic fire
[Applause]
house
watch the people fall in the crowd boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom
I just felt the worst
[Music]
survive cancer to die here tonight I
told her I got her I've already lost two
girls I'm not losing another one
sorry
we were arm in arm Carrie was on my left
and we're running
and that's when she said you know Kelly
I've been shocked I just saw all of
these doctors coming down the hallway
and in the back was a guy with a
clerical collar and I
which I just knew and that was it
I didn't want to leave it
so
sorry
why do you need an assault weapon that's
really for war why do you need more than
10 rounds of ammunition
I'm looking at what the heroes did that
night people risking their lives for
other people
there's a very heavy weight that goes
with being the Storyteller it's
important that people know the truth I
don't think there was any one of us that
thought we were coming out the same way
that we went in
foreign
country radio host stormy Warren who you
just saw in that setup clip uh joins us
now you were there that night uh in in
the clip you're the one who said there's
a very heavy weight that comes with
being the Storyteller you are part of
this story
it's got to be hard to relive though
yeah it's it is we relive it every day
everybody was there 22 000 of us we'd
live it and we feel it and we see it and
we hear it every day we find a way
through therapy and a lot of other ways
to find a safe spot for this story to
live but now with this documentary out
it's all coming right up to the surface
again you know the confusion of those
first moments you're at a concert it's a
lot it's loud people are dancing a lot
of movement and then you hear the pops
and you were backstage at the time it
was on stage yeah there's a few of us
off down stage right and you know a few
songs in any old bar stool is playing
with Jason Aldean and we're here
pyrotechnics is it what we didn't know
what it was and a long time friend of
mine said who's been on the road on
concerts forever said that was not
pyrotechnics and this was not Technical
and then the second volley hit and then
the third and then we said it's about
time to get off the stage after seeing
literally like you saw in that clip the
body's dropping right in front of us and
bullets hitting the stage a bullet hit
Tully's the bass players base
um and Jason and the band get off stage
we get off stage and we're hiding behind
a little concrete barrier and that 11
minutes was might as well have been 11
hours just the fact that it was 11
minutes that's that's the thing that got
me I intended to just watch one episode
therefore I watched the first one and
then I couldn't stop because I've never
seen anything like kudos to Susan
sarinsky and see it now Studios who put
it together because I thought you guys
really took us there behind the scenes
stories like stormy where one woman had
to have her chest open with no
medication and is told by the doctor and
nurse this is going to hurt but we have
no choice we have to do it now I'm
always fascinated by these stories
because the news moves on yeah and then
you guys are still left with all these
wounds if people are still covering
recovering we're still traumatized can
you just explain what it has meant to
you you said nobody can comes out of
this unchanged no how you were changed
and you tell a very compelling story
about a girl in red shorts that you're
still haunted by uh though everybody has
their own image or own sound or
experience or memory of that night and
they're all different that's what's
beautiful about this four-part
docu-series is it weaves everybody's
individual stories together I have a
better picture of what happened were you
reluctant to take part in this
absolutely why
um because you I didn't want to relive
it again we relive it every day I didn't
see
what I could do to benefit this project
I'm glad I did it now because it's so
well done yeah I was nervous about how
the story was going to be told I
remember asking one of The Producers
Sarah I said if it's anything but a
timeline of the night I don't want a
part of it um I don't want theories I
don't want speculation I don't want
agendas and none of that's in there no
you took us there you took us there so
how are you changed and who's the girl
with the red short
um the girl in the red shorts is what
changed me
um I went after the shooting I went out
into the bowl and it looked I hate this
analogy but it's the only one I could
come up with I could only imagine what
Normandy looked like because there were
just bodies everywhere it wasn't like
one or two it was dozens of bodies yeah
and in they were not it was not very
good condition no and um and this one
girl who's curled up in red shorts
everybody had somebody around them
everybody had family or friends or
caretakers or Heroes First Responders
she did not she was alone and so I
wanted to go to her and I did know she
was alive or she had passed but I needed
to go check on her and I got yanked away
at the last second to go care for some
other people and I never got the chance
to go back and check on red shorts you
um you had a strong reaction to the list
of mass shootings that have happened
since
um the last October 1st 2017 and this is
at the end of the documentary tell us
about that reaction and why
um the analogy I recently came up with
and I'm so glad I did because it's so
true watching the last seven minutes
it's a scroll of all the mass shootings
yeah just text a lot of names a lot of
names and it takes almost the exact same
amount of time as the 11 minutes did and
so my reaction was the same I started
getting angry and started yelling at the
TV it's like stop yes same thing we did
when the shots were fired so it's
powerful the whole thing is so well done
I I really I can't say enough how people
should see this because we don't see
storytelling like this after an event
like this yeah because you think they've
survived there fine there's so much you
move on people move on but they can't no
we don't no we don't it's the rest of
your life that you're dealing with
absolutely all right so many Warren
thank you very much for being here uh
you can stream the four-part documentary
11 minutes now on Paramount plus which
we are proud to say much like CBS itself
is part of Paramount Global yes we'll be
right back thank you all